It's just something
we don't like to think about.
No-one talks about it,
no-one really wants to address it.
My husband's very much: "Don't want
to talk about it. Nope. You're fine."
I don't want to talk about my death
too much with them
because I don't want to make them
feel more unhappy.
It's even more difficult
if you're faced
with somebody that you love
who's got a diagnosis
and then you have to start
this conversation.
You don't have the language
because you’ve never talked about it.
You don't have the familiarity, you
don't know how to open the question.
In our society we're often encouraged
to plan for our lives.
Planning for our births,
planning for different operations
if they need to happen,
and also, as an extension of that,
starting to plan
for our end-of-life care.
And that's increasingly important,
because more of us have a period
where we are dying
rather than just suddenly dead.
So there's a chance to think about
what that period will look like.
When those questions
are looking back at you
and someone is saying,
"What do you want?"
It makes you really sit down
and think about
all the places that you might want
to have your ashes scattered,
or whether you want
to die in hospital,
to come home and die,
what are you going
to do with your animals?
Who's going to look after your
husband when you've gone?
Families might make the assumption
that they will be able to speak
on behalf of their loved one,
and it's not an automatic thing
that they can do that.
It's important that they legally
nominate a family member
by making them a lasting power
of attorney for health and welfare.
It's a comfort knowing that my
parents have power of attorney
and they can make those decisions
when I'm not able to
rather than a doctor or somebody
who doesn't know me very well.
Just nudging doctors
in the right direction, so actually,
"Do this, but don't do any more"
or, "This is not what I would have
wanted" is incredibly helpful.
Legally we can't demand
certain treatments,
but we can definitely
refuse treatments.
So people can say they
don't want to be resuscitated,
or they don't want
to have artificial nutrition.
I think a funeral plan is extremely
helpful.
Carl had made one, my husband,
before he died.
So we did know what
he wanted in his funeral
and what he didn't want.
That kind of practical thing
was such a comfort to the family.
Allow them to grieve for you,
instead of having to worry
about the 'what ifs'.
"What if we've done this wrong?"
We don't turn up and say:
"Let's talk about death."
Or: "Tell me what you want
if I tell you that you're dying."
You sent me your
Advance Care Plan booklet
and I've filled that in
up to a point.
Although when it came
to the, you know,
"Do you want your window
open or shut? Or your light on?
Or what about your hygiene?"
And I thought: "No - I can't
even think about that."
But it is simply a case
of getting things together
so that it's easy for my family.
By documenting this information now
you are at the centre and we,
as professionals, and your close ones
and family, will do the best we can
to make sure you have the care
and the preferences you want.
It's really important that you tell
your GP or your healthcare provider
what your preferences are
if they relate to medical options.
It's important to let your
friends and family know
where they can find that document
if it's in a particular part
of your house.
Disabled young people don't
necessarily want to be focusing
on more planning
which is around their illness
or their disability.
Personally for me I feel like
I've spent a lot of time
negotiating my health, negotiating
the support that I receive,
the care that I receive,
my diagnoses,
and so I want to spend any extra time
or extra energy that I have
really living, and making sure
that I'm doing the things
which I think are important.
Within healthcare these days,
there's an expectation,
both from healthcare professionals
and patients,
that people can have a say
about what's important to them.
However that can put
a lot of pressure on people
to make sense of quite
a vast array of information
and at a time when they actually
might want to defer
the decision making to someone else.
If we have to, and you're not able
to tell us what you want,
we will do what we think
is best for you from what we know.
It's not a yes, you've got a plan
or no, you haven't.
It's more of a kind of evolution
of thinking.
And you can revisit them and change
them as your life is progressing
or as your values are changing.
It's a true gift of love because
you're taking away that burden.
Put your wishes down, file away,
and forget about it.
Focus on the important bits of living
and getting on with life.
We insure our house,
we insure our cars,
we insure our pets.
Why are we not insuring ourselves?
Nobody's going to say, "Well
Adil didn't say what he wanted".
Because I did
and it's there on paper.